hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
near the end of section 8 of the inquiry
concerning human understanding david
hume has a
treatment of what you can recognize as
the classic problem
of evil which has to do with
you know whether god is in some way
responsible for
or accountable for the badness that we
encounter in our experience and in
the world and we're running throughout
human history as well
and hume's argument here
or his treatment his his account
ultimately doesn't tell you the
conclusion that he's
tending towards which is really that
classical theism is
fundamentally wrong in asserting that
there is a god of the sort that
christians
tend to believe in this you know creator
of everything
omnipotent all good all those sorts of
attributes hume is not actually going to
come out and say that
instead what he's going to do this is
kind of a typical
argumentative technique that you see for
example in the dialogues
concerning natural religion is raise
you know a problem and then say well
here's some
ways of addressing this and then say
well you know these these ways of
addressing it
here's how they're framed but they're
not very good
are they so therefore something else
must be the case and that something else
in this case would be classical theism
gets
taken off the dock because hume wants to
hold on to
this what he calls doctrine of necessity
and and you know it makes perfect sense
from a human
point of view it's much more plausible
for him it's much closer to our
experience
that everything is necessitated that for
every
event there is some sort of set cause or
set of causes that produces it
so for human actions there are always
motivations
they may be complex they may operate in
weird ways that we don't fully
understand but they all do necessitate
what it is that we do so that you know
voluntary
actions are voluntary in the sense that
they come from us and our faculty of
will is involved but our faculty of will
doesn't like waver
between them and engage in some sort of
deliberative judgment
and then use its power to choose one
over the other instead
we just act the way that we do so
let's start with what he has to say
he he tells us that
this is a objection to his theory
i can foresee other objections derived
from topics i've not treated of
and then he says it may be said for
instance that if voluntary actions be
subjected to the same laws of necessity
with the operations of matter
then there's a continued chain of
necessary causes
pre-ordained and predetermined
reaching from the original cause of all
to every single volition
of the human creature no contingency
anywhere in the universe no indifference
no liberty while we act we are at the
same time
acted upon so the idea there would be
whatever illusion we have of
freely choosing things that's that's not
what's really going on
as a matter of fact we're behaving the
way that we are
in the present because of this entire
long
chain of causality that goes all the way
back
to god and there's a couple
interesting implications if that's the
case if we've got this chain of causes
going all the way back
to the omnipotent omniscient all
good creator the ulti he says the
ultimate author of all our volitions is
the creator of the world
who first bestowed motion on this
immense machine and placed all beings in
that particular position
once every subsequent event by an
inevitable necessity must result
so what are the what are the results of
this well we're
posed with an interesting dilemma which
goes against our ordinary
ways of thinking about things
human actions would not be bad
there would be as hume as saying no
turpitude
in them turpitude is coming from the
latin terpe which means badness right
there wouldn't be any genuine
evil caused by human beings they have no
moral turpitude
why because they proceeded from such a
good
cause god is good so therefore whatever
god created is good
even if it means my screwed up motives
and emotions and
psychological dynamics that lead me to
be a jerk to people
well that's fine because god made me
that way and people do in fact make
those
sort of excuses i'm this is just the way
i am right uh
and then we often say to them no it's
not you have a choice
or if that's really the way you are and
you're not happy with it change yourself
so we don't completely accept this but
we would have to accept that if we
really believe that
god is the cause of all of our volitions
and actions
or there's another possibility
god himself itself whatever god is
is involved in that very turpitude
or badness right he says
they must involve our creator in the
same guilt while he's acknowledged to be
their ultimate cause and
author and here hume has an example of
something that
is a little harder to relate to he says
a man who fired a mind is answerable for
all the consequences
whether the train he employed be long or
short so a mine is an explosive
charge that you set off and whether you
have a long cord
or whether you're doing it with you know
a blasting machine or something like
that
you're the one who actually triggered it
so whether it's
years and years of history or god
reaching into my head and you know
monkeying around with stuff in there
right now it doesn't matter
god made me do what i'm doing in some
way god is the cause of this
so if there really is badness in it then
god's a bad god god's a bad whatever
god can be judged on that basis
and hume says well you know both of
these are
things we don't want to really buy into
how can we
address this so he before that though i
i do want to say one other thing that he
points out here he says
our clear and unalterable ideas of
morality establish this rule upon
unquestionable reasons when we examine
the consequences of any human action
these reasons must have still greater
force when applied to the volitions and
intentions of a being
infinitely wise or powerful with human
beings we can say human beings are
screw-ups
so therefore when human beings like make
another human being do things
it's entirely understandable that the
screwed up human being making the other
screwed up human being do things
produces bad results but god isn't
screwed up
he says ignorance or impotence may be
pleated for a human
but those imperfections have no place in
our creator
he foresaw he ordained he intended
all those actions of men which we so
rashly pronounce
criminal so we have to conclude either
they're not criminal
or that the deity not man is accountable
for them and then he says
ah you know we can't accept either of
these why these are both absurd
and impious so it follows the doctrine
from which they're deduced cannot
possibly be true
as being liable to the same objections
so
what's he rejecting here he's actually
rejecting this chain of causality going
all the way back to god
because he's going to reject that
there's any god for the chain of
causality
to go back to so he's using
some of the basic suppositions of
religious believers against them
and he answers the first objection that
okay human actions aren't bad and he
does some kind of an interesting way he
talks first about
this is the classical distinction
between what we call physical or natural
evil and moral evil you know physical
evil as an earthquake happens your house
falls down
something hits you on the head crushes
your skull that's bad
right or a tsunami comes washes you away
destroys you know thousands of human
lives and all this this
stuff that they've made that they're
dependent on that sucks
but it's nature doing it it's not some
person like
pushing a button and killing a whole
bunch of people that would be moral evil
right and sometimes physical and moral
evil can kind of cooperate together
you know you build a whole bunch of
houses on a flood plain
and then the flood comes by and
everyone's like i never thought the
river would ever go beyond its
boundaries even though it's like flooded
five times in the last 10 years
physical and moral evil have cooperated
in that case right
but he says uh you know with physical
evil we could say okay so god sets up
the universe
and it works certain ways and bad things
happen but they're not really bad
because it's all part of the one big
scheme in which it all works out for the
best and he talks about different people
holding those sorts of views not just
christians but also stoics
and then he says and here's why it's not
really answering that objection
he says that's not much consolation to
somebody who's got gout
gout is a very painful disease that you
get in your legs
and it has to do with you know diet in
large part he talks about the malignant
humors being involved we would say you
know the other physical processes
your legs hurt you and you can't walk
around very easy because you're gouty
because of all of these other causes
that are taking place
tell somebody who's got gout that it's
all part of the general scheme of the
universe
and they'll be like yeah that's not
really much of a consolation to me
it's interesting philosophy or theology
but that doesn't really
work for me right and then he talks
about moral evil right
and he says that the case is the same
with moral as with physical evil it
cannot
reasonably be supposed that those remote
considerations which are found in so
little efficacy
with regard to the one will have more
profound influence with regard to the
other
it says that the way our minds are
formed is when somebody does something
to us that we don't like we're not like
oh well you know chain of causality
going all the way back to god
that person could it couldn't have
helped doing what they do
it's just the way the universe is formed
no we're like that sob
i want to punch him in the nose we get
upset about it
and we want other people to be upset
about it too right
so this first objection that you know
human actions
aren't ever bad because they trace back
to god hume is
is you know supporting it and then
taking that support away
the second objection is even more
interesting right
saying that god would be involved in
that badness
he says well this
maybe could be answered but he says it
admits not of so easy and satisfactory
an answer
nor is it possible to explain distinctly
how the deity can be the immediate cause
of all actions of men without being the
author of sin and moral turpitude and
then here
he sort of punts it to theology he says
these are mysteries which mere natural
and unassisted reason the philosophers
work right is very unfit to handle
whatever system she embraces she must
find herself involved in
inextricable difficulties and even
contradictions
right to reconcile the indifference and
contingency of human actions
with prescience or to defend absolute
decrees and
yet free the deity from being the author
of sin
has found has been found hitherto to
exceed the power
of philosophy so you know you're saying
this
you know maybe there is a solution to
this but it's not one for philosophers
theologians step in and and handle this
now is hume being a fetus here and
saying oh you know this is where reason
comes to an
end and we must listen to the voice of
revelation
no not really he doesn't really buy that
because you can you know read his
dialogues concerning natural religion or
his natural history of religion
and come away with the the impression
quite rightly that
he doesn't buy any of this theistic
stuff at all so
kicking the the ball down field to
theology
is just sort of like letting it go off
of a cliff and so he hasn't really
satisfactorily addressed either of these
objections
hume does think that there is a doctrine
of necessity right
and so he's committed to that so the
implication then is well let's
take god out of the picture so he's
doing something quite
clever here that you have to kind of
look behind the scenes
to figure out exactly what's going on
and
that that is his treatment of this issue
of
god and evil and necessity
you